bonjour bienvenue à tous nous sommes à
Bruxelles au Parlement européen pour
cette nouvelle édition d'Europe Hebdo
dans cette émission direction l'Autriche
un pays où le taux de chômage des jeunes
et d'appel neuf pour cent un rêve pour
la plupart de ses voisins européens
notamment au sud alors le modèle
autrichien d'apprentissage est-il
transposable nous en débattrons avec nos
invités mais d'abord l'actualité l'UMP a
voté a désigner ses têtes de liste pour
les européennes non sans polémique c'est
la question de la semaine
enfin après des semaines de
tergiversation l'UMP a voté les têtes de
liste aux Européennes sont donc
désignées et après les accros de ces
derniers mois entre leaders du parti
c'est le temps de la paix des braves et
c'est l'histoire comme d'habitude
quelques surprises Alain Lama source
parachute du Sud-Est à l'Île-de-France
pour laisser la part belle à 1000
Alliot-Marie
resortefeux Rachida Dati mais aussi
Nadine Morano ou Jérôme l'avrieux les
bancs du Parlement européen risque de
Fort de bruisser des conversations du
mouvement populaire d'anciens ministres
ou des proches des dirigeants qu'il
faudrait recaser après une défaite
électorale en somme en attendant mieux
alors le Parlement européen est-il une
salle d'attente pour des politiques en
mal de
le Parlement européen salle d'attente
pour des politiques en mal demandés
c'est Arnaud Denjean qui va répondre à
cette question bonjour merci d'être avec
nous vous avez donc été investi numéro 2
sur la liste dans le dans l'Est avec
Nadine Morano en tête de liste alors
qu'est-ce que vous pensez un petit peu
de ce casting de l'UMP sur ces têtes de
liste on voit quand même beaucoup de
politiques à recaser en mal demanda le
Parlement est une chambre tante
finalement
non je ne pense pas c'est toujours une
polémique qui fleurit au moment des
désignations des tenuesistes ou des
binômes pour chaque élection européenne
c'est le même refrain dans tous les
partis politiques d'ailleurs et il y a
un peu de polémique à mon avis excessive
parce que quand on regarde c'est un
c'est un dosage entre les gens qui
montrent et ceux qui sont reconduits
j'ai coutume de dire que moi-même il y a
5 ans j'étais entrant j'étais nouveau
donc je peux pas me plaindre d'un
système qui renouvelle aussi les cadres
donc voilà je crois qu'on fait un peu de
bruit ce qui est vrai malgré tout c'est
que la tension qui est porté à la
constitution de ces listes ça se fait
toujours un peu une extrémité et c'est
ce qui renforce ce sentiment un petit
peu de malaise et je pense que le vrai
problème de fond il est moins un moment
de la désignation des têtes de liste en
dépit du bruit que ça peut faire que sur
la durée du mandat ou je pense qu'il
serait bon que les appareils politiques
les états majors parisiens de tous nos
appareils politiques français se
préoccupent un peu plus quotidiennement
pendant la durée du mandat de ce qui se
fait au Parlement européen vous par
exemple durant votre dernière mandature
vous vous êtes senti complètement
éloigné de l'état-major parisien en gros
vous diriez que l'UMP se fiche un petit
peu ce qui se passe à Bruxelles
dont le premier secrétaire siège
pourtant en tout cas est censé mais donc
tous les partis politiques français ont
le même tropisme qui est un tropisme
très franco-français alors ça peut se
justifier à bien des égards mais c'est
vrai que quand on compare avec nos
parlementaires nationaux on fait figure
un peu de parents pauvres dans l'intérêt
qui est porté à nos travaux ça c'est un
petit peu amélioré pour être très franc
j'étais pas loin de terre européen avant
mais de ce que me disent mes collègues
qui sont là depuis plusieurs mandats je
trouve que lors de la dernière mandature
m'a quand même
eu des contacts un peu plus étoffés
bon ça reste quand même très en deçà qui
se passe pour beaucoup de nos collègues
européens d'autres nationalités en gros
il faudrait dire merci la crise
finalement qui a remis un peu l'Europe
au centre de au centre du jeu c'est vrai
leurs éléments il y a eu aussi le fait
que pour ce qui concerne mon parti vous
en parliez
on a été aux responsabilités donc dans
cette période de responsabilité
exécutive en France il y a eu un lien
avec l'Allemagne qui était très fort et
qui amenait ici un certain nombre de
dispositions à prendre avec nos
Allemands
nous avons été élus et moi-même je mets
mon élection le compte très largement de
la présidence française de l'Union
européenne exercé par Nicolas Sarkozy
donc évidemment ça renforçait quand même
un peu le lien et la dimension
européenne mais encore une fois ça
restait très insuffisant par rapport à
ce que connaissent d'autres pays
pour revenir justement sur ces listes le
problème qu'on voit maintenant c'est que
à force en fait de venir recadrer
d'ancien ministre en fait mandat ou des
proches en fait des dirigeants on voit
Jérôme labrio qui est l'ancien directeur
de cabinet de Jean-François Copé
il y a quand même une perte d'influence
prégnante de la France au sein des
commissions quand on voit que
l'Allemagne en fait reprend un petit peu
toujours les mêmes les mêmes députés
est-ce qu'il y a pas un risque ici de
voir l'influence française au sein des
institutions c'est rodé
indéniablement mais je ferai pas de
systématisation pourquoi par rapport aux
entrants et aux sortants regardez le cas
qui me concerne moi j'étais entrant la
dernière fois donc j'étais tout à fait
novice et pour autant j'ai des crochets
une présidence de commission que
j'estime exercer honorablement qui est
un vecteur d'influence pour pour mon
parti et pour pour la France plus
généralement tout en étant encore une
fois un primo entrant donc je ferai pas
de cette Lucas par cas ça dépendra
vraiment de l'application que chacun moi
je ferai pas de potentiel d'intention à
telle ou telle parce qu'il n'est parce
qu'il est ancien ministre ou parce qu'il
est cadre du parti quand Nadine Morano
dit que elle a l'intention de CG de
manière durable au Parlement européen
vous le croyez jamais procès d'intention
à faire encore une fois tout est David
des députés sortants qui vont peut-être
être en roue libre et dire bon bah moi
j'ai déjà été élu j'ai déjà fait un
mandat c'est plus tranquille voyez donc
je ferai pas de procédé d'attention
c'est du cas par cas ça dépendra de
l'implication un ancien ministre peut
avoir un impact ici il y a beaucoup
d'anciens ministres voir d'anciens
présidents d'autres pays qui sont ici et
on leur fait pas le reproche d'être dans
une salle d'attente ou dans une salle de
recasage donc voilà il y a des coups de
projecteurs qui ont été mis et c'est
bien naturel au moment de cette
compétition interne je crois malgré tout
que le encore une fois le le procès
d'intention est parfois un peu un peu
excessif alors il y a eu un autre procès
d'intention je souhaiterais qu'on écoute
en rigolant en rigolo pardon qui est
député UMP des Yvelines qui a
semble-t-il quelques soucis éclatés de
liste qui a été investi par le MP on
l'écoute
la tête de liste en Île de France
un prince sa marque très profondément
sur la ligne des fois tendues par l'UMP
on a il a été décidé que elle serait
confiée à la Massour il incarne une
certaine idée de l'Europe plutôt
fédéraliste plutôt dans la ligne de ce
qui se construit depuis une trentaine
d'années
moi je fais partie de tous ceux qui a le
MP
et parmi les Français regarde cette
construction d'un regard critique
aujourd'hui voilà qu'on décide de
rajouter en tête de liste quelqu'un qui
incarne une ligne qui est qui
déséquilibre complètement l'une de l'UMP
alors c'est la question que tout le
monde se posait lors du Conseil national
quelle est la ligne sur l'Europe de
l'UMP finalement
tout à fait éloquante et claire par
Jean-François Copé qui a commencé son
discours en disant ce qui est la vérité
ce qui est la vérité depuis très
longtemps ce qui est génétique à l'UMP
l'UMP est un parti européen dit derrière
que il ne veut pas non plus de cette
Europe là
il y a des choses à revoir on est tous
conscient qu'il y a des choses à ajuster
mais c'est de l'ordre de l'ajustement
c'est pas de l'ordre là j'entends de la
déconstruction de la d'abord la
déconstruction c'est pas au Parlement
européen qu'elle se fait il faut savoir
pourquoi on élit les députés européens
les députés européens ils sont là pour
peser sur l'orientation des législations
européennes ils sont pas là pour
déconstruire l'Europe ou là ou la
reconstruire ça ça va être au moment des
présidents que l'orientation fédérale ou
moins fédérale ou tout ce qu'on veut et
ces mots m'agaces prodigieusement parce
que ça correspond pas aux réalités mais
si on veut peser sur l'orientation de
construction européenne le Parlement est
une des reste pierre de cet édifice mais
le vrai pouvoir il reste aux exécutifs
nationaux donc orientation c'est à ce
moment là qu'il se montre les
présidentielles en France qui ont pèse
vraiment sur l'orientation de la
construction là au niveau des élections
européennes ce sur quoi on pèse c'est
sur l'orientation des législations
européennes donc il faut pas tout
confondre il faut pas que se débat
européen pour les élections
parlementaires deviennent un débat pour
tout où chacun arrive avec ses
frustrations par rapport à l'Europe
telle construit aujourd'hui c'est des
voix qui font entendre mais moi je
refuse ce discours qui consiste à dire
les élections européennes sont décisives
pour savoir si on déconstruit l'Europe
ou si on en reconstruit une autre
sondages qui indiquent que Marine Le Pen
et le Front national vont être le
premier parti sur ces européennes est-ce
que là on n'est pas dans cette éternelle
clivage de l'UMP qui court un petit peu
derrière le FN parce que on est dans
cette espèce de ligne un petit peu
militants de l'UMP je dis vous trompez
pas vous trompez pas d'enjeu encore une
fois sur des élections européennes on va
voter pour élire des représentants
français qui vont venir siéger dans une
assemblée où il y a 751 enfin il y en
aura 700 un peu plus de 750 membres
est-ce que vous croyez que 20 membres de
l'UMP vont construire l'Europe ou la
reconstruire dans une assemblée de 760
personnes évidemment c'est pas ça le
sujet premièrement deuxièmement on peut
être profondément européen et triote moi
j'attends qu'on vient de me faire des
procès en patriotisme j'ai travaillé
pendant 10 ans au ministère de la
défense française quelle institution
souveraine par excellence au niveau
national je préside d'une commission de
sécurité de défense j'ai un attachement
profond viscéral à ma nation je suis pas
pour autant anti-européen donc ces
débats sont un peu stériles c'est des
débats très franco-français en plus qui
se posent beaucoup moins dans les autres
pays un petit peu en Angleterre mais on
a vu le cas anglais mais la faute de
l'UMP aussi mais moi ce que je voudrais
dire c'est regarder ce qui se passe chez
nos confrères allemands la cd-out c'est
sous c'est un parti évidemment
profondément européen et qui va faire le
procès à ces députés allemands ou à ma
mère qu'elle de ne pas être une patriote
allemande donc Cesson
ces petits bonhommes en bleu sont le
symbole d'une réussite
dès la lotrichienne ou l'apprenti est
roi Jean-Marc Ayrault est venu chercher
des solutions aux problèmes du chômage
des jeunes en France ici le taux de des
moins de 25 ans est un des plus bas de
l'Union européenne
8,7% seulement
il est encore tôt qu'en radoven enfile
son bleu de travail dans la banlieue de
Vienne la capitale autrichienne c'est le
début des cours au Centre
d'apprentissage you Gundam verk entendez
la jeunesse au travail le jeune homme
s'équipe et sous l'oeil de son formater
il s'exerce à la soudure
ok tu sais faire avec cette machine
c'est bon pour toi ok
on peut le faire
40 % des jeunes Autrichiens vont vers
l’apprentissage depuis 2008 chaque jeune
qui termine l'école obligatoire à l'âge
de 15 ans étant droit de recevoir une
formation quand il ne la trouve pas
seule l'état autrichien l'oriente le
suit et le forment à un métier Radovan
lui veut devenir sidérurgiste
à travailler ici plutôt que d'être
simplement assis à l'école je suis très
confiant sur le fait de trouver un
emploi le secteur de la métallurgie est
très demandé surtout quand on a reçu une
bonne formation on est presque sûr de
trouver un travail en sortant d'ici
ici on s'organise en atelier autonome
moins de Casa d'apprentis par classe la
journée débuta 7h15 elle s'achève à
16h15
c'est presque la même chose qu'en
entreprise ici sauf que là nos profs
prennent vraiment temps pour bien nous
expliquer ce qu'on va faire c'est pour
ça que ça me plaît
l'Autriche le royaume de l'apprentissage
comme son voisin allemand il fait figure
de modèle et c'était depuis ce bureau du
emploi autrichien que le système est
piloté
on peut voir juste au milieu de l'écran
le chiffre du chômage dans le pays et
juste au dessus là vous voyez on peut
lire le chiffre de près de 3000 nouveaux
chômeurs aujourd'hui
avec ces écrans Yohan escob fait à la
tête de l'AS le Pôle Emploi autrichien
quand certains voient des effets pervers
dus à l'orientation trop précoce des 15
ans lui il voit la raison de la réussite
il y a d'abord ce test c'est important
de savoir ce qui intéresse les jeunes la
première question que veux-tu faire est
déjà mauvaise la réponse est souvent
rien la question doit être est-ce que ça
t'intéresse c'est aussi ce que veulent
les entreprises les entreprises veulent
des gens enthousiastes qui communiquent
trois années d'apprentissage avec la clé
un certificat et une réussite garantie
près de 90% des jeunes trouvent un
emploi les entreprises sont friandes de
ces jeunes qualifiés
puisse leur travail et ensuite il va
couper cette pièce là ça va être
Grenelle et ensuite je vais utiliser la
machine là-bas et pendant sa formation
le jeune homme est même payé 300 euros
par mois pour la première année 700
euros pendant la dernière fumer
ça me convient ici j'apprends je ne suis
pas là pour l'argent
j'acquière des compétences pour plus
tard c'est surtout pour ça que je suis
ici
depuis 2006 ma Martine s'est à la tête
de ce centre de formation intermédiaire
250 apprentis et un objectif pédagogique
que ces jeunes évoluent vers l'autonomie
professionnelle mais aussi social
il y a toujours des jeunes qui arrivent
ici pour lesquels on se dit ils n'ont
pas confiance en eux mais on voit leur
évolution après un ou deux ans ils
échangent ils osent ils se réjouissent
même quand il réussissent un stage avec
un retour positif de l'entreprise ils
comprennent qu'ils sont coupables quand
on les voit devenir adulte et avoir une
évolution si positive se prendre en main
c'est gagner
il y a au total une fois soixantaine de
centres d'apprentissage dans tout le
pays l'Autriche consacre l'un des plus
gros budgets de l'Union européenne et
pour l'État c'est un gros investissement
130 millions d'euros pour faire
fonctionner le progrès le ministre du
Travail est lui-même un ancien apprenti
employeur employé on travaille ensemble
pour créer ce système de formation et il
continue à le développer constamment ça
a toujours été notre prioritaire en
Autriche de donner du travail aux gens
même en cette période de crise plutôt
que de payer la location chômage nous
préférons investir de l'argent pour
qualifier les gens
en classe Radovan et ses camarades
suivent aussi des cours théoriques
compris dans la formation aujourd'hui
son avenir est tout tracé
oui bien sûr j'aimerais que mes enfants
fassent la même chose j'ai accumulé de
bonnes expériences ici et ce n'est pas
fini je trouve l'apprentissage très
important car ensuite les portes sont
toujours ouvertes si on veut faire un
autre métier et si on y arrive pas on
peut toujours se réorienter dans le
secteur de sa formation
les entreprises doivent chercher des
employés qualifiés c'est très important
quand on ne sait pas exactement où on va
travailler plus tard
lutter à tout prix contre ce chômage des
jeunes en Autriche un objectif zéro
chômeur
en 2016 pour les jeunes des scolarisés
l'information deviendra obligatoire et
les sanctions seront lourdes jusqu'à des
amendes pour les parents
l'exemple donc autrichien est-il un
modèle à suivre pour débat de ces
questions je reçois deux députés bonjour
mesdames Evelyne Gabin vous êtes député
allemande Bernadette vergnot vous êtes
française et vous avez toutes les deux
travaillé sur cette question alors je me
tourne vers vous madame madame est-ce
que c'est un exemple à suivre après tout
on a l'impression un petit peu de
réinventer l'eau chaude non c'est un
exemple à suivre mais je crois qu'il
faut l'adapter à chaque pays en Europe
chaque pays est différent il a eu une
histoire et une culture différente mais
je crois qu'en France nous avons
vraiment perdu beaucoup de temps il est
indispensable d'avoir un socle
intellectuel un socle on se cultive
intellectuellement on apprend les
savoirs indispensables et en même temps
par exemple un jeune qui s'ennuie dans
une classe quand on voit qu'il a pas
envie d'apprendre il faut que
relativement jeune on puisse développer
toutes ces capacités de création
d'innovation et de rêve d'avenir et
ça passe par l'artisan par les
professions j'allais dire alors actuel
sous-estimé dont l'enseignement en
France on n'a jamais été capable de
faire travailler vraiment de façon très
serrée l'éducation nationale les
artisans et les grandes entreprises et
je crois que là on a pris beaucoup de
recul même si on commence maintenant
parce que c'est la crise a avancer dans
ces domaines-là mais c'est indispensable
et un jeune à 16 ans si par exemple il
apprend à créer chez un artisan
l'artisan l'artisan c'est du la création
mais c'est aussi de l'art parfois et je
crois que si on avait pas dévalorisé
tout ça dans la tête des jeunes dans la
tête des familles et bien je crois que
là on pourrait être comme Autriche comme
la Finlande comme l'Allemagne ou comme
l'Allemagne justement cet exemple
autrichien c'est un petit peu aussi
comme ça que ça fonctionne en Allemagne
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait finalement
transposer tout ça à d'autres pays
européens notamment donc la France ou
les pays du Sud qui connaissent je pense
notamment à l'Italie 40% de chômage chez
les moins de 25 ans je dirais que le
système malmet c'est un très bon système
pour l'Allemagne parce que nous avons
une culture une tradition dans ce
domaine c'est une tradition aussi il
faut dire où les entreprises sont
partis prenantes et s'ils ne le sont pas
alors c'est très difficile à faire donc
il faut réellement ajuster dans les
États membres la manière dont ça peut
être fait mais je pense que la
plus-value qu'il y a dans ce système
c'est que les jeunes ont cette éducation
à l'école et l'éducation en entreprise
c'est-à-dire il commence déjà à
apprendre comment ça fonctionne dans une
entreprise à faire valoir ce qu'ils ont
appris avec leur propre main parce que
pas tous les jeunes sont des
intellectuels et je pense que dans ces
métiers c'est une des métiers très fort
en fait et une grande force de
l'Allemagne justement c'est d'avoir une
productivité très poussée main d'oeuvre
qui est très capable et c'est à cela
qu'il faut le voir c'est un petit peu le
modèle allemand aussi à ce niveau là
quoi à ce niveau là oui c'est une des
bases c'est une des bases les jeunes qui
et qu'ils ont ça dans la tête et dans
les mains et je pense que ça c'est une
des grands avantages justement vous
parliez de dévalorisation en fait de ce
modèle de
d'artisans et de métiers annuels la
classe d'âge 80% d'une classe d'âge au
bac c'est un petit peu ce qui a tué
l'artisanat et les filières manuels
françaises là on revient finalement 40
ans en arrière quoi non mais je crois
que c'était une bonne idée quatre parce
qu'on a besoin aussi chaque citoyen a
besoin dans sa vie d'être responsable et
pour être responsable il faut avoir une
base solide comme le disait madame
guebar d'une base solide et
intellectuelle mais en même temps les
savoirs fondamentaux je crois que c'est
indispensable par exemple qu'un jeune
puisse être capable de faire une demande
d'emploi sans faire de fautes
d'orthographe et sans faute de français
ou d'allemand enfin peu importe mais
c'est indispensable certes mais en même
temps ne pas
occulter toute la capacité
personnelle de création dans chaque
individu et il y a des individus et ça
se détecte très jeune au collège on le
voit bien qui ont envie d'être
technicien automobile ou artisans
menuisier et on a tué ça parce qu'on a
pas comme le disait madame guépard
justement eu en France par exemple une
culture dans l'entreprise à l'école et
d'école dans l'entreprise et ça je crois
qu'on le réinvente on le réinvente parce
que c'est fondamental et la directive
sur les qualifications professionnelles
sur lesquelles on a travaillé ensemble
parce que j'étais rapporteur mais
Evelyne et coordinateur dans notre
groupe je crois que c'est la dimension
européenne qu'on a voulu donner c'est
vrai que si on veut sortir de la crise
et si on veut que les jeunes avancent et
les moins jeunes d'ailleurs il faut
aussi leur donner de la mobilité
professionnelle mais la sécuriser et
sécurisée leur parcours professionnel
alors justement lors d'un sommet
européen qui a été donc derrière suivi
d'une visite dans la Merkel à Hollande
pour cette question du fromage des
jeunes il y a eu l'annonce en fait d'une
espèce de garantie jeunesse avec une
enveloppe de 42 milliards sur 7 ans pour
6 millions de jeunes alors on va pas ici
faire des additions mais c'est quand
même une petite goutte d'eau qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez de la communication
il faut faire quelque chose c'est bien
clair mais je pense que les avancées que
les États membres ont fait sur les
avancées quand même très timides très
très très timide et je pense qu'il faut
faire beaucoup plus et quand la
Commission européenne dit nous devons
faire quelque chose pour les jeunes et
de dire mais c'est aux États membres de
le faire je dis c'est malheureux c'est
malheureux nous devrions en faire
beaucoup plus au niveau européen
d'autant que la plupart des pays
confrontés sont des pays en crise on
pense à l'Italie on pense à l'Espagne
exactement
et la politique est faite en ce moment
dans l'Union européenne justement pour
les pays dans le sud c'est une mauvaise
politique parce que c'est la politique
qui crée le chômage des jeunes en fait
et c'est un incroyable donc nous devons
pas seulement donner de l'argent pour
l'éducation nous devons faire aussi en
sorte que les règles que nous avons dans
nos États membres soit plus social et
plus juste pour les jeunes surtout et
qu'ils aient aussi une perspective dans
leur vie et donc je pense qu'il y a
beaucoup de choses à mettre à plat et
pas seulement un beau projet qui est un
petit commencement trop timide et mais
il faut en faire beaucoup plus c'est
qu'en 2000 milliard c'est une opération
de communication c'était juste de
l'annonce pas seulement je crois qu'il
faut enclencher le processus mais il
faut aussi qu'il y ait enfin un souffle
européen un esprit européen la crise
est-elle
mais bon il faut absolument qu'on essaie
concrètement de créer cette marché du
travail européen où il peut y avoir des
opportunités que chacun puisse saisir à
un moment donné dans sa vie et nous
c'est ce qu'on a fait mais au niveau du
Parlement on est beaucoup en avance
là-dessus par rapport aux États par
rapport aux Français
en commun de formation à la fois
professionnel et à la fois intellectuel
dans les universités etc ça ça déjà
commencé mais quand j'ai posé la
question au conseil et Madame Gabart en
était témoin ça a été en non on
n'arrivera pas et bien on y arrive on a
longtemps pour cette carte
professionnelle européenne
déjà
on y est arrivé tout de même à force de
vraiment convaincre donc c'est possible
est-ce que vous diriez que le processus
mais c'est possible au niveau du
Parlement il y a une volonté
effectivement d'agir sur ces questions
il y a une envie de l'Europe plus
sociale qui protège en fait notamment
les jeunes qui en ont le plus besoin
c'est quoi c'est le conseil c'est les
gouvernements nationaux qui bloquent qui
finalement sont là dans une stratégie
ce sont les gouvernements nationaux qui
regardent de trop près leur propre
situation et ne pense pas d'une manière
globale d'une manière européenne de
manière à faire des plus-values communes
on a toujours quand on voit les Conseils
européens quand ils sortent quand nos
chefs d'État Madame Merkel et les autres
sont pour gagner ils ont tous gagné et
surtout ils ont fait quelque chose
contre les autres et contre leur c'est
dommage c'est dommage au lieu de
chercher la plus-value européenne au
lieu de faire que la carte
professionnelle que nous avons enfin pu
mettre en route mais seulement sur une
base
volontaire nous nous voulons
sur cette question de de l'apprentissage
comment est-ce qu'on pourrait mettre en
place un système qui puisse fonctionner
au sein de tous les États européens
n'existe pas de Pôle Emploi européen
n'existe pas de système d'éducation
nationale PP1 est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose en fait à pouvoir creuser sur ces
questions là déjà je pense que pour
rebondir sur ce que dit Evelyne gebaert
quand on parle d'éducation au niveau des
États c'est national compétences
nationales quand on parle de l'emploi
quand on parle de l'emploi les affaires
sociales
on voit bien qu'en période de crise il
faut qu'on se fédère à la fois nos
systèmes de formation et nos systèmes
sociaux donc à partir de là il faut
trouver quelle est la bonne
harmonisation qu'on peut construire et à
un moment donné vous compense
automatiquement plus-value européenne et
non pas seulement socle national et ça
on a beaucoup de difficultés et quand on
a voulu par exemple que les stages dans
cette rective les stages soient des
contrats qui soient sécurisés et
reconnus après la mobilité
professionnelle c'est énorme moi je suis
allée en Espagne plusieurs fois faire
des Colocs quand on dit ça au jeune
campagnols qui sont au chômage par
exemple plus de 50% au nom d'allure
quand on leur dit qui pourront
bénéficier d'un stage qui sera reconnu
c'est un contrat ça sera pas bidon et
qui après ils auront aussi une carte
professionnelle qui leur permettra
d'avoir un cursus marqué tout au long de
leur vie tout ce qu'ils feront même si
ça dure six mois un an on sent une vague
d'espoir
ce n'est pas absolument que politique
résonne aussi comme eux et comme nous et
ça on a du mal parce que on parle plus
value européenne mais on parle pas
vraiment fédère à Sion coopération
dernier mois rapide madame gobarthe
justement sur cette plus-value
européenne et sur cette volonté de
d'uniformiser est-ce que vous y croyez
encore oui j'y crois je ne crois pas à
l'uniforme ma vie parce que elle est les
traditions les cultures sont trop
différentes mais des rochements des
plus-values une plus grande ouverture
entre les États membres justement dans
le domaine de la culture de de
l'éducation de la formation
professionnelle serait vraiment la
bienvenue écoutez merci mesdames d'avoir
été avec nous pour évoquer cette
question nous c'est la fin de cette
émission vous avez rendez-vous la
semaine prochaine avec à dire bonne
semaine sur les chaînes parlementaires
égalité